enjoy your life fiber optics to
the home brings
people together download and upload files at the
speed of light bluray in 33 minutes
dvd in 6
minutes
300 photos in 58
seconds real-time interactivity
stay
connected drive innovation fiber
optics to the home  home enables new
services content and
applications remote surgery
telemedicine smart electrical grids
smart grids
video surveillance systems on-demand television
home theater
cloud computing online games videoconferencing and
learning boost your business
communicate faster effectiveness
and
quality avoid
traffic jams work from
home and reach
everyone go green with fiber optics
to the home The future is now
fiber To The Home council
europe creating a brighter future